The hi my name is katy beslado
i'm the director of ibm quantum strategy
and applications research i'm here to dispel
as many cotton computing this
as possible in sixty seconds.
The one of the beautiful absolute real
and we have devices on the ibm cloud now that anyone can access.
Yes but only for certain things they're really good at doing
super complicated math like the universe runs on
but if you want to do spreadsheeters than an email use
your pc.
Yes theoretically but not
for a while no one makes the computer good enough to do that
yet for the foreseeable future were on track
and when we get there we're gonna change the way we protect
information.
The completely false quantum computers
are fundamentally different
and use the laws of nature to process information
today's ai run on good old fashioned classical devices
but we do believe they'll partner in the future.
Not true we have a tremendous ego system
of start up academia national absent industry partners that
are using our devices every day the.
No corner inspired has been around
for a long time and runs on classical devices they
won't ever deliver on the promise of corner computing
if you wanted you commuting you have to do it with real quantum
computers